okay we're back on
and we'll see what he's got
playing this
silly line again
oh now he's playing fast
so he goes for
[Music]
this line okay so his improvement is to
go queen a5 immediately
and now if i do play bishop a3
there is d4 and both my pawns are pinned
okay and if i play bishop b5
there's still d4 no then i can take on
c6
yeah whatever i'll go bishop e2
i didn't really think bishop
bishop b5 was too convincing
you probably could sack a
sucky pawn there after
d4 efficiency six bc6 knight d4 and then
maybe bishop a6
looked a bit unpleasant maybe
this one i just missed though
okay now i clearly clearly misplayed it
a bit
okay i need to
need to actually study this these
openings rather than just
playing them down on a whim
it's probably studying the consequences
of d4 here
i'm sure i'm not sure it's great though
okay i'll put my mouth where
mommy is is that the expression
yeah i don't know
i'll bite the bullet
there
okay we'll take it i don't see why i'm
losing here so
bishop d3 bish b3 bish b2
maybe rook takes e2 immediately was more
dangerous
this one i'm sort of feeling that i
should survive
e1 maybe queen a6 i have to go king d2
then which is not a deal
on the other hand probably not so bad
rook c1 was my first
intention but then i'm also running into
neither for knight d3
forks after queen eight for a sixth
point was
then i could go c4 but i was still not
threatening to take and
didn't seem so convincing now i would be
thrilled to see knight c3 of course i
would just run to f1 with the king
um this one is considerably more
dangerous for me
but i have some sort of a solid
construction here
i hate the fact that my king is in the
center and it
will be there for a while but it does
feel as though i'm still protecting
everything
and this chain of pawns on
c3 d4 and c5 is really it's really quite
quite strong um and it's not so easy to
break up
let's say he goes b6 then i have
queen b5 which is quite annoying for him
he then retreats to c8
i can possibly even push the pawn to c6
so it's it's not obvious what he can
what he can do here
um clearly has some compensation
and the quick the queen can swing
wherever it wants on the
on the sixth rank but then i will go g3
um after queen g6 i will go g3
queen of six um i don't think there is a
there is an actual threat
after that most so it's it's not so
clear i think queen b5 is a good move
um no no not only because i'm driving
the queen
away but also um
because i'm probably improving the
the the queen uh it can go to d3 later
on and protect my king
i will go a5 now just to avoid any
b6 breaks
yeah this is really tense queen of five
this one i don't like
because i'm not gonna go quindy three
was tempo
queen g4 now it will go g3 i believe
um now i think king c2 and then bishop t
two should be good
okay we got bishop d2 now
i think he has drifted a bit here
uh
gotta be careful still
i should probably have included f3
before i go for this
okay i'll go c4 it does loosen my
structure a bit but
it also seems to to improve my position
so
i quite like it now d5 is on the cards
okay 97 don't think this does a whole
lot
i just push queen c7
now we go queen d4 this one i'm not too
worried about i just push a6
okay he lost some time but the position
was dead last at this point
b6 i go c6 and he cannot
even pretend to to bother my king there
okay if my calculation is not way off
that
concludes the match
um and i gotta say it was a pretty tense
match
um but overall i think
i was a lot better we were both short of
time
and it felt like in some games he was
sort of missing the critical
critical moments i'm very hap unhappy
with the fact that i lost the game
as i said i would have loved to keep
keep a clean [ __ ]
if not sweep him but nevertheless
it's a it's it's an emphatic scoreline
against a very
very strong strong players player so i
shouldn't shouldn't be
shouldn't be on